hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at the petrel defense
which charts out with Pawnee for Pawnee
v both sides trying to control the
center nigh develop to f3 central square
like responding with Knight f6 central
square both sides attacking and
defending the center and this is a
mirror image from black and this is done
for a few reasons a lot of GM's like
this because it's a very draw game
marrying the other side at the beginning
like this a lot of other players do it
to avoid the typical lines from the boy
Lopes the Italian game the gioco piano
that you'll see come about after most
black players play Knight to c6 so it
kind of a change in pace we're going to
go over today the three common lines
that you will see and how both sides
should react when you do come across
them the first one that you will see
more often than not of the three is
Knight to e5 captures on e5 and it if
you look at it right away looks very
tempting for black to recapture on e4
trying to equalize the material right
away but this is going to be a huge
mistake if you play as black you don't
want to do this and if you play as white
we're going to show you how to take
advantage of this mistake you can simply
play Queen to e2 attacking this Knight
if the black then responds to f6
thinking that after he's equalized the
material he can just go back to his
normal square of f6 now white can bring
his knight to c6 with a discovered
attack on the King and winning this
Queen even if the Queen moves to e7
defending the Queen check y can still
capture with his knight if he doesn't
move his knight back to f6 White's still
going to be up in material by at least a
pawn if black tries to move like d5
adding protection on his knight on e4 y
can now come add more pressure with a
move like D
three then if black tries to push the
game with a move like Queen to e7
attacking counter attacking our Knights
on e5 we can completely disregard this
take with our pawn and after he takes
our Knight we can capture on d5 safely
knowing that he can't take our pawn
because our queen is eyeing down his
king he can exchange Queens or doesn't
have to but either way we're going to be
up in material by at least upon which is
a very good game for white so if you do
in the beginning see white capture on
excuse me why capture on e5 do not take
right away instead you want to play d6
and what this does is it forces white to
move and then allows black to capture on
e4 safely so many times you'll see
Knight to f3 and then black can come to
e4 and from here there's a few options
that white has one that you'll see a lot
is pawn to d4 trying to solidify the
center and from here blacks going to
continue to push with pawn to d5 keeping
white from pushing down any father and
at the same time solidifying his knight
on e4 making it very difficult for white
to push it away right away sometimes
though you may not see d4 you may see a
move
like Knight to c3 and from here black
has the option if he wants to open up
the game remember this is a very draw
game but if he wants to open up the game
a lot of players that especially for
white they'll make this move because
they want to instead make it draws make
it very aggressive and this comes about
if Knight captures on c3 white can
recapture on c3 with this pawn a lot of
times you'll see it more often in the
roy lopez exchange variation but if
there's double ponds on the c2 and c3 or
even on the black side of c7 c6 more
than likely that side is planning to cap
castle on the Queen side so if we assume
that why it's going to castle on the
Queen side black capture castles on the
Kings side it's going to be in a very
aggressive game anytime both sides
castle on opposite side it's pretty much
a race towards the other person into
keen the both sides can pretty much
kamikaze all their pawns and pieces on
the side of the other King and not
forfeit any of their defense they have
for their own King so again for both
sides if you do want to open up the game
and make it a little more aggressive you
can just go ahead and bring your pot
excuse me your Knight to c3 and then
after the exchange white can take on c3
and then Castle queenside so that's the
first variation that you'll see is if
Knight captures right away on e5 the
next variation that we're going to take
a look at is the most common and that is
d4 play disregarding the first pawn and
from here black has two options he can
take on d4 or he can take on E
I personally recommend taking with our
knight on e4 I think it's a great square
for our Knight and I just don't like the
complications that come about after
taking with our pawn on d4 so from here
y can bring his Bishop to d3
there's no reason right away keep in
mind in the petrel defense a lot of
times the Knights are being forced to
move more than once at the beginning so
it's okay not to take this pawn right
away why it's going to get that material
back from here black has a few options
the most common option that you will see
is pawn to d5 putting added pressure on
to this Knight here from here white can
bring his Knight to e5 and a lot of
times here you'll see a continuous
mirror image of Bishop to d6 and as you
can tell from this game as it is a
mirror image this game is very draw if
you do like to play very Josh positions
in the petrov offense you will also like
this one as well so those are the two
most common that you'll see in the
petrel defense next we're going to take
a look at the third and last one that
you will see after E 4 t5 f3 f6 the
variation that you will see is the three
Knights or the four Knights attack and
that's just Knight to c3 and from here
black has two options he can have a
Game of the Petroff three nights attack
which is Bishop to b4 attacking this
Knight pinning it down once his White's
pawn moves on the D file or you can go
into the four Knights game which is
Knight to c6 so a lot of players will
play this knowing that their opponent is
going to get into the four Knights game
where if they play the Roy Lopez and
started out with their Knights on f3 and
c6 more than likely they know it would
not get to the four Knights game but if
a black player is very fond of the four
Knights game and wants to get there more
than likely he's going to try to get
there using the petrel defense instead
of starting with knight c6 he's going to
first start out with Knight f6 and then
after the Knight to c3 he's then going
to move his knight to c6 from here white
has a lot of different variations you
can study up on the four Knights game he
can even go into the Halloween gambit
but there are a lot of different
variations in the four Knights game the
very from any other game that you will
see so hope you guys enjoy the petrov
defense video if you haven't already
please subscribe if you haven't checked
out the website www.chesterlaw.com make
sure you check it out thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys next
video